well large homeless encampments have
formed at two schools
in seattle including a middle school but
members of sales school board are
demanding
the mayor's office keep the encampments
in place once again a story you can't
believe is real but jason rants of
seattle confirms it is
he's a radio host there he broke the
story he joins us with details jason
good to see you
good to see you tucker i toured the
encampment just a few days ago at meaney
middle school this is one of the schools
that's impacted it's one not really far
from the autonomous zone
and it's attached to a park and that
park serves as one of the ways that you
get to this actual school and it's
simply
overrun with homeless and i'll be honest
i lost
count of the amount of tents that are
there around 40 maybe 50 there's trash
absolutely everywhere i was briefly
followed by a homeless man with a metal
pole that he was banging on his hand
in sort of a menacing way and despite
being careful
i managed to step on a syringe now
thankfully
no needle was attached but i mean
imagine what's going to happen with more
kids showing up right now you've got
some kids there
these are special education students but
schools are set to reopen
in washington state in just under two
weeks in this internal email
to the mayor that i was able to get my
hands on school board director zachary
dewolf
asked for ideas on how to handle the
situation that's happening there
but in no uncertain terms he said and
this is a direct quote i want to say
very clearly
this is not an ask for a sweep but the
city was going to do a sweep anyway
because they realized that these people
who are homeless are not taking up
any offers of resources they're not
going into shelters
and that's when publicly the school
board president her name is chandra
hamson
she put out a joint statement with
devolve basically demanding that sweeps
never be performed on school grounds
adjacent or elsewhere
and they put never in all caps so
they're very very serious
this is dystopia that they've created
why do they believe that
vagrants the right of vagrance to live
next to a school is more important than
the right of kids not to step on
syringes and be hassled by vagrants
where do they get that idea do you think
well kids are privileged they live in
homes and thus they are not
deserving of any special protection like
people who are homeless through no fault
of their own
and this is not just happening here in
seattle and certainly not just happening
at schools i mean look at the 10 cities
for example that are happening in the
other washington washington dc
it's it's there's video right there
taken by someone
a friend of the show that's yards from
this probably 200 yards from the capitol
on l street under a bridge
and you've got to kind of wonder is
nobody noticing this this is the world
they're creating jason rants i
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you it's dark but it's good to know it
thank you tucker
i appreciate it